i'm an introvert by nature it's i'm
really not an extroverted person who
likes to go out and like
i like to be at home with a couple
friends and have a late night
conversation over good food like that to
me is a perfect night read a good book
listen to a podcast go on a walk
um you know those are things that i
really really enjoy
and suddenly i'm in this life where i'm
like supposed to be something that i
really don't want to be
except for on stage which is a really
fast like strange thing to me which is
on stage i feel so free and exuberant
and like
an extrovert and then i come off and i
just feel like shrivel back into a show
like it's a it's i i music does that for
me and performing on a stage does that
for me can we take a small attention on
this yeah of course what's the high
can we go through that the introvert
that wants to cuddle up and read a book
you're the front man of one of the if
not the biggest rock bands
today
uh playing in front of huge crowds
what's the high of that and how can you
land back on earth
high of it
is it's incredibly beautiful
to
walk on a stage
sing
these songs that you wrote
and see it resonate with people around
you and sing with them
different cultures different places
celebrate life it's suddenly the world
seems like a fantastic place it feels
like we're all on the same team
like one big hug yeah it's like
everybody in that room gets it and they
all
like it it just
if it feels like what you want the world
to be which is just like this
co-existing unit of people and it's not
even about like
you know
i just it's incredible it's for sure
it's incredible and i love it and i
wouldn't do it unless i loved it
and then you walk off stage and you turn
on the news and it's like you see you
know we're all against each other
everybody hates each other and it feels
that way in the world so music really
that's why live music is so important to
people that's why music is so important
to people
because even if it's just you and that
person that wrote the song you're
listening to it and the two of you feel
connected
you know it's like
you're hearing tracy chapman sing like
fast car or something you're just like
oh my gosh like yes i get it and you
feel connected that person you don't
feel alone like
so that's the high of it for sure and
then you get off stage and then
you know
as my like my uncle is a heart surgeon
incredible heart surgeon who like writes
the book like he's like the guy that the
heart surgeons talk to he's out of
nashville tennessee he's just incredible
genius man
he um
always worries and always reached out to
me he's like musicians die all the time
the reason they die
you know is because you're getting on
stage and your heart's doing this and
your cortisone levels are doing this
you're getting off stage and then you're
just doing this
and it's a really real thing like you
get off stage and you feel like you need
drugs because you're like i
the world feels like
oh incredibly daunting and it's also i'm
sure it has to do with like some some
like health things in your heart and the
cortisone levels that are so crazy and
then you come off and it's like
i know people are like well then
nothing's enough except meth yeah right
nothing's enough except heroin yeah and
that's why a lot of artists turn to that
stuff and and i don't say it in a preach
i don't say in a preachy way like i've
struggled with drug abuse in my life
and
i really
i understand
why artists turn to it um
but also the fact that you're introvert
so the other side of it
the fame
that's something that you also said is a
double-edged sword for you the
interesting thing about fame
is that you also mentioned this is
something you can't take back
yeah so it's the thing
you can't just like go on vacation in
hawaii and it's like consider do i like
it or not no you're staying in hawaii
for the rest of your life and you've
never been there before
whether you like it or not right so
um what's that like
being
you know loved by millions and millions
and millions of people
which is um
perhaps the best kind of fame in terms
of if you had to choose the kinds of
fames there are
and
still being an introvert and all that
kind of stuff so what um
do you feel alone more alone being
famous is there a loneliness there's
yeah i mean it's so it's such a funny
thing because for okay if you had asked
if we were having this conversation a
couple years ago i'd be incredibly
guarded about this because
the last thing i want to ever
do is sound ungrateful
or unaware of how much i have and woe is
the famous celebrity with money oh is
your life hard is it really telling me
about how hard it is but i'm also at a
place in life now where i just like i'm
gonna always just speak my truth because
that's the only reason i'm here is i'm
here to speak my truth to you so i'm
gonna tell you my truth whether it's
whatever it is well you're human and
feelings are real
and so and right that's the interesting
thing you win a lottery what's that
going to feel like it's not about
complaining oh it's so hard to win a
lottery because you get a lot of money
no it's still you're human you get to
experience these feelings and it's
fascinating you put humans in different
situations right and and it's also
fascinating because a lot of people
think well i would like to be famous
that's a big thing now on social media
on instagram so the world wants to be
famous or rich or famous and it's very
interesting to think all right well once
you arrive
are all the problems solved no yeah so i
will tell you according to me what the
pitfalls are whether it's fear or not
and there are certainly some pitfalls
one it's once you're there you can't go
back
whatever maybe that's fine because maybe
you love it yeah but
the real pitfall for me is that
you're now you're lex and you're what
everybody's perception is that lex is
and that's what you are
now
lex is probably a lot more complex and
complicated and has a lot more to lex
than the lex that is the celebrity yeah
so
but anybody who meets you
that's who you are to them
and you may
you may not feel this way but you may
feel confined to actually have to be
that person to that person like i early
in my career for a long time anytime i
met someone i suddenly felt like i had
to be dan reynolds from imagine dragons
anytime i met someone including my
family now who are also like whoa this
is crazy you're like dan reynolds from
imagine dragons yeah and i wanted to
just be the goofball that i have been my
whole life
with my brothers and family but suddenly
i found myself feeling like no i i have
to be this
like because that's who that's who this
is
so you're almost like playing a role and
it's like i've heard a lot of actors
talk about this well they take on a role
and then it's like they feel like they
have to they like become that and it's
a really scary thing like you you alter
who you are almost
to fit the notion of other people
because especially if
a lot of artists are empaths
it you know a lot of people get into art
in a deep way are empaths and so you
feel a lot of what people are feeling
and you're never wanting to burden
people and you're always wanting to
deliver to that person
you know what they want it's like people
pleasing is very goes hand in hand with
a lot of like
these famous people and they get to
where they were because they know how to
do that they know how to be in a room
with someone and look them in the eye
and
make them feel like they're the only
person in the room and then now they got
that role in that movie because they sat
with the casting director and they were
like oh you're so funny has anybody told
like put on the charisma do it all and
it's like
anyway i'm like i'm going on a different
tangent here but
long story short
there's a lot of things that are really
unhealthy about it and then a lot of
people who want the fame then the second
starts to go away then they're like who
am i anymore like that was everything
and now i'm like on the down and now i'm
not a famous person anymore and now i
hate myself now i'm gonna do drugs and
it's like it's like this vicious cycle
like you can never be famous enough
you're always going to get like
there's just so much to it that i've
just and i and and again like
i've i've lost friends in this career to
to that for sure um
and there's a certain element to sort of
just on the
the losing fame of interacting with a
lot of folks
um
especially young folks like in youtube
so fame is a thing
that has levels
you're always trying to be a little more
famous a lot of folks who are chasing
fame it doesn't matter how famous you're
always trying to chase more and when you
start to lose it
interesting things can happen if you're
not self-aware which is like
like you mentioned
you might be trying to grasp back
at where you were by leaning into the
formula that got you there and so the
the the constraints of the image that
you mentioned
becomes the thing that you're now trying
to lean into like and that that's
actually walking away from who you
really are like you lean further into
being that person that's true for acting
that's true for
um even on like youtube which is people
acting they have a role they got them to
the table somehow yeah it's uh it's dark
but i i think those are
that's just
put for everybody to see
um but that's a very human struggle even
when you're not famous
finding yourself of being yourself of uh
not letting not doing the people
pleasing
at any scale yeah and being trapped by
that yeah and and also feeling like it's
never enough i think that's something
all he like
it very no it's not just a famous thing
but it's like in the whole like
everybody deals with feeling like when
i'm here i'll be happy yeah when i get
that job i'll be happy when i have that
money
then i'll be happy when my when i get
that surgery and my nose looks like this
i will be happy then it's like an a
constant chase of happiness instead of
happiness
it's like the opposite it's opposite of
self-love it's the opposite of of
uh it's there's no presence to it you're
constantly you're never going to find it
you're never going to arrive and you're
just going to live your life and then
you're going to be on your death bed and
be like i was chasing the wrong thing my
whole life you know
i should say that podcasts are
interesting in that way so for me
personally because you just talk a lot
you can't
people that meet you they know you and
they know the evolution of you and
that's the same thing for like you right
now a dad of imagine dragons just being
on a podcast like long form reveals a
side
that liberates you more to be yourself
to like people see oh there's a human
because they you know music they have a
deep connection with you they have
experiences
with you the way they experienced it and
that's who you are with them through the
songs but now you get to see oh that's a
that's a human being he probably gets
angry he gets sad he's excited he's
hopeful you know and there's a core
that's a good human being but the whole
roller coaster of emotions out there
it's a giant beautiful mess and podcasts
reveal that that's why i love podcasts
like long form right you get to get to
hear some artists and actors and so on
and some of them
you get to see oh you've
lost yourself
in the uh
in the surface that's a tragedy with
some actors some great actors
if they've
they've left so much of themselves in
the roles they've played
that they can no longer
be
the thing they were before those great
roles that's for sure it's
it's hard it's hard to see so you get to
see that with johnny depp with i don't
know pirates he was talking about that
with pirates of the caribbean that was a
shift right like he's now that guy right
he's he's forever
forever that guy
but the point is to remember that you're
not and to your family which is
interesting you said with your family um
when i see people close to me they also
there is an element like that while
you're that they start treating like the
famous person yeah you know i i'm
fortunate to have
my manager who's my brother
my older brother
and my lawyer is my other older brother
and
that's been helpful because
the ma like it's weird it gets weird
with everyone no matter what one of the
best advice i was given was by uh
charlie sheen you got advice from
charlotte yeah we were playing uh the
wise sage of our generation yeah why is
sage charlie sheen but he it was it was
really wise i was sitting next to him
and we were we were
playing some late night television and
he said this was right at the beginning
he just said boys
just mark my words your life is about to
get really weird that's all i said but
it stuck with me forever as charlie
sheens of course it sticks with you
and i remember being like right okay
charlie you know i'm not charlie sheen
it's not gonna get weird like you know
um
but it got really really weird really
quick because suddenly
you've existed your whole life in this
way where everybody just
everything you get
you achieved it was because you got it
and and every conversation you had like
if someone liked you at the end of that
conversation was because they liked you
if they didn't like you because they
didn't like you
and you could make complete peace with
that at least i could my whole life i
was like life is a challenge
and be myself and i want to go through
it and find some people along the way
that i connect with and others know and
that social
integrity
is so important to us
and we think it would be nice
to have this and this is going back to
the the pitfalls of fame we think it
would be nice to walk into a room and
have everyone be like
yeah and you could be like
dumpster fire and everybody's like oh my
gosh dumpster fire that was amazing you
said dumpster fire was amazing
it's like
it's incredibly
incredibly lonely and it just breaks
everything that you knew about
humanness yeah and it sucks so then
you're seeking out
people who
that it doesn't exist with and families
the closest you can get to that for sure
but even your families it's going to
take a little bit where they're like oh
this is a little weird like all my
friends at work are now asking about you
and you're my young stupid brother but
now you're suddenly like the young
stupid brother they want an autograph
from and stuff and it still makes like
they have to get over that and figure
that out and
and um
and then you meet people too who know
about this whole concept and they're
like well i'm gonna be an [ __ ] to him
to show him that i don't
subscribe yes
and you're dealing with like people who
are like dumpster fire and the person
who's like
you know you could say something
actually profound and nice and they'd be
like that's stupid and you're an idiot
because it's like an actual attempt to
like show you how much they don't care
so you live in this very like
this still nevertheless even when nobody
knew you you were seeking for deep
human connection with a small number of
people
and now when a lot of people know you
you're still looking for deep connection
with a small number of people the
struggle is the same
you